ancient Greece had its fair share of
deadly creatures and monsters both on
land and sea if I were to ask you to
name the first Greek sea monster that
comes to mind it's likely that many of
you would say Silla but just opposite
the cliffs at silla called her home in
the Straits of Messina deep in the ocean
was an enormous whirlpool created by
Charybdis a gargantuan sea monster that
plagued the coast of Italy for years on
end Charybdis may be how we pronounce
her name now but in ancient Greek it was
pronounced Hardy these and many believes
her name to have originated from the
Greek word meaning to swallow the
creature was said to be so large that
she consumes so much water when she
belched it created an enormous whirlpool
the exact size of this wall Paul was
never mentioned but for it to have been
big enough to swallow up an entire Greek
ship it's been estimated that it would
have had to have been over 75 feet
across interestingly enough the area
what a monster is located in the Straits
of Messina does actually contain a
whirlpool but this one is caused by the
currents meeting and it's too small to
cause any real danger
there are several stories that attempt
to discuss the origins of Charybdis the
oldest been that she was a daughter of
Gaia the personification of the earth
and pontus the sea in the years that
followed her father was naturally seen
as Poseidon as he became the ruler of
the sea Charybdis always remain loyal to
Poseidon and drew in a feud between duce
and Poseidon over land she aided her
father engulfed in small islands and
large patches of land in water this of
course left Zeus furious the land had
been stolen from him say he captured
Charybdis and chained her to the seabed
he then cursed her into the form of a
hideous monster with flippers for arms
and legs and an uncontrollable thirst
for the sea the fact that she was
transformed into a hideous monster by
Zeus makes it more than likely that she
could have been one of the Oceanics one
of the nymphs of the sea there is a
similar story where she is instead
portrayed as a greedy woman who chose to
steal the cattle of Heracles Zeus with a
single thunderbolt once again cast her
into the sea where she would literally
become a whirlpool the physical
appearance of karibdis as we've already
seen has changed over the years some
believe that she was nothing more than a
personification of a whirlpool away for
the ancient Greeks to explain this act
of nature
other stories describe her as a human
that was transformed into a monster an
occurrence that is not too uncommon in
Greek mythology but exactly what this
monster looked like can be left down to
your imagination some saw her as an
enormous whale like creature and so
others Charybdis resembles something
that you dicks
to see in the work of HP lovecraft an
enormous gaping mouth of gigantic teeth
waiting to swallow anything that came
her way with Charybdis been such a great
monster of the scene as one would expect
she does appear in several noticeable
works and stories in homers work
theodicy Odysseus finds himself in quite
a poker s position in between karibdis
and Scylla but Decius oddities meant to
avoid Charybdis as that would result in
their ship being swallowed so instead
they passed through Scylla and after
losing several men they were forced to
pass near curb this anyway
the ship was sucked into her jaws and
Odysseus clung on to a fig tree
eventually when Charybdis exhaled the
boat was released and after recovering
it Odysseus made his way to safety
karibdis does also feature in the story
of jason and the argonauts who also
faced with this impossible task in
traveling through the narrow passage
with Charybdis on one side and silat on
the other
in this story however the goddess Hera
ordered the mother of Achilles Thetis to
guide them to safety these two Siemens
has been so close to each other creates
this narrow pathway which essentially
acts as a deathtrap sailors would come
across Charybdis living under a rock in
a narrow channel of Messina and Scylla
on the opposite side on the much larger
cliffs of Silla
this meant that sailors passing through
would have to choose which of the two
dangers they would rather face many like
in the term between Scylla and Charybdis
- between a rock and a hard place which
refer to someone being faced with two
equally undesirable alternatives which
is exactly what these two months is
presented this thing created the near
impossible task for sailors to chart a
course that avoids both of these
monsters without delay in their voyage
with so many stories and interpretations
of how curb dust came to be and what
exactly she look like I'd love to hear
what you guys think let me know in the
comments below